olmeda est une wayuu
chaque dimanche après midi une voiture
de sa communauté vient la chercher pour
l'emmener dans son village
je rentre dans ma communauté parce que
je fais institutrice je dois m'occuper
de mes élèves
dans cette région il ya beaucoup
d'enfants qui souffrent de malnutrition
la zone où on va au centre de laguarigue
c'est là où il ya le plus de misère
dans la péninsule de la guajira un
enfant sur trois souffre de malnutrition
depuis le début de l'année c'est une
hécatombe ils sont plus de 60 à être
mort de faim et de soif
[Musique]
pour survivre
certains dressent des barrages de
fortune
il reste là toute la journée à attendre
par 50 degrés
[Musique]
elle est
en plein essor ils sont là en plein
soleil ils attendent qu'on leur donne
quelque chose
ce qu'on veut bien leur donner
karine kasakwa pas témoin
mais
ce petit vieux il fait payer son péage
c'est une coutume ancestrale
on est à côté de sa maison et comme on
est sur son territoire
on doit payer sinon passez par
la plupart de ces gens n'ont que ça pour
vivre
[Musique]
en trois heures de voyage la voiture
passe une quinzaine de péage chacun
donne ce qu'il veut
à un petit billet
une bouteille d'eau
[Musique]
et
même un peu de nourriture fait la faire
[Musique]
au bout de la piste quelques maisons au
milieu du désert
c'est ici que vit la famille d'almeida
dans ce paysage désolé il y une
ressource plus cher que l'essence
plus précieuse que tout l'eau
l'eau ici c'est de l'or
c'est impossible de trouver de l'eau
[Musique]
chez les wayuu l'eau c'est d'abord une
affaire de femmes
c'est à dire une corvée de tous les
jours
[Musique]
à l'heure où le soleil des kills à peine
olmeda et les femmes du hameau entame un
long voyage pour aller au puy
le chemin qui y mène était autrefois le
lit d'une rivière
il y à bien longtemps qu'elle est
asséchée
chose incroyable ces enfants n'ont
jamais vu la pluie
voilà cinq ans qu'elle ne tombe plus
[Musique]
amine al
c'est
en marche une heure et demie parce qu'on
est avec les enfants ils vont pas vite
la température est très élevé il fait 40
43 degrés au moins
au bout d'une heure et demie de marche
la récompense
[Musique]
c'est le seul pays qui n'ait jamais sec
il fonctionne toute l'année
les habitants ont tour et le puits d'une
barrière
il ne faudrait pas qu'une bête vienne le
polluer
les wayuu prennent ce trou d'eau comme
une bénédiction
pourtant l'eau est salée à peine potable
mais elle est tellement précieuse
près de cent familles sont ravitaillées
chaque jour à la sueur de ses femmes
les femmes travaillent plus que les
hommes moi je travail de cinq heures du
matin à 10 heures du soir
vous avez leur triste bien sûr on
souffre beaucoup à cause de l'eau si on
avait de l'eau à la maison on serait
heureux mais bon qu'est ce qu'on peut y
faire on peut pas partir on est né ici
on vit ici on y à nos parents nos grands
parents ils ont vécu ici et ils sont
enterrés ici ou est-ce qu'on pourrait
aller on n'a pas d'autres terres
ailleurs moi je suis né ici et je
mourrai ici
[Musique]
il faut maintenant entamer leur tour
encore une heure et demie de marche
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
la balle
à cordes et ça ressemble non
pas la nécessité
d'où votre baril
[Applaudissements]
dépasse
les roannais effet
souvent pour faire venir la pluie les
wayuu se retrouvent afin de célébrer
laâyoune à
la danse traditionnelle de la gloire il
a
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tata l'une des plus jeunes femmes de la
communauté a deux enfants
elles s'inquiètent pour leur avenir
je rêve d'une vie meilleure pour les
enfants
j'aimerais qu'ils puissent étudier
[Musique]
comme tous les enfants de la communauté
la fille de tata va à l'école à pied
dans ce désert elle fait partie des
rares enfants qui ont la chance
d'étudier
dans la guari là il n'y a aucune
infrastructure
pas de route pas de transports scolaires
[Musique]
certains enfants font jusqu'à deux
heures de marche
ans
leur cartable et leurs uniformes ont été
offerts par une organisation humanitaire
mais quand même
[Musique]
les enfants habiteraient loin
il arrive entre 7h et 9h le matin
comme annoncé
et canapés rocaille nom associé à
higuain
- chez les oies naines et maya
et comme tous les jours le moment que
les enfants attendent le plus
est celui du repas
[Musique]
ainsi kakwata
chez eux ils n'ont rien à manger
c'est le seul repas qu'ils ont dans la
journée
et il est plutôt sommaire
de la farine de manioc de maïs est un
peu de lait en cours
[Musique]
j'espère qu'il va pleuvoir
mais ça m'étonnerait
ce jour là une fois de plus l'orage a
grondé
mais la pluie n'est pas tombée
même le ciel refuse de verser une larme
sur le sort des royaux
si le ciel ne peut rien pour eux les
ouailles ont compris qu'une seule chose
pouvait les sauver désormais
la contrebande
eux aussi sont
ce ballet de moto au milieu de la nuit
ce sont les trafiquants d'essence wayuu
qui rentrent du venezuela avec leurs
bidons
[Musique]
ils font l'aller retour tous les soirs
à leur tête oui
j'ai des journées compliquées c'est
illégal ce que je fais la police peut
m'arrêter et la loi colombienne est très
sévère avec nous
j'ai peur de la prison
[Musique]
avant comme tous les wayuu williams
cultiver la terre et élever des chèvres
ça fait deux ans que je fais de la
contrebande
avant j'étais berger
j'ai hérité du troupeau de mes grands
parents
mais aujourd'hui les chèvres ont disparu
dessiné par la sécheresse
williams se prépare à livrer les sens
acheté la veille au venezuela
d'abord on attache bien ses deux
premiers bidon ça fait 120 litres puis
on rajoute un troisième bidon et en a
180 litres
je ne peux pas mettre autant d'essence
sur ma moto n'est pas en très bon état
alors je regrette un peu les pneus
c'est toujours dangereux de rouler dans
le désert avec le sable on peut tomber
facilement espère très mal
tous les hommes de la famille participe
au business
[Musique]
à cinq motos ils arrivent à transporter
chaque jour près de 900 litres d'essence
si la police les arrête elle saisira la
cargaison et leurs engins
[Musique]
mais les ouailles ont un avantage
ils connaissent le terrain par coeur les
sentiers caché au milieu des cactus
un vrai labyrinthe
[Musique]
les derniers kilomètres sont les plus
risquées car ici le convoi n'a pas le
choix il doit emprunter la grande route
avec ses patrouilles de militaires et de
policiers
vous avez peur que la police vous
attrape
si on se fait attraper il peut aller en
prison
chaque année ce convoi qui n'a l'air de
rien fait entrer illégalement en
colombie plus de deux cent mille litres
d'essence
[Musique]
derrière ces palissades
la maison du patron du cartel de
l'essence
nous avons interdiction d'entrée
[Musique]
on rit bien cent vingt mille habitants
la capitale du pays voyou la seule ville
où l'on peut faire ses courses
william réinvestis immédiatement son
salaire
l'aja environ 100 euros
c'est ce que j'ai gagné dans la journée
mais cet argent gelé réinvestir
je vais doubler mon bénéfices en
achetant du maïs que je vais revendre
venezuela
essence contre nourriture
une vie au marché noir
mais comme tous les wayuu williams ne
partirai d'ici pour rien nous mêmes
c'est la terre de ses ancêtres
il préfère mourir que de l'abandonner
[Musique]